when people learn the JavaScript
supports so many different class
patterns they frequently wonder which
one they should be using or which one is
best
and sadly there just isn't an answer to
this question as a language JavaScript
takes remarkably few stances and tends
to make the internal features visibly
available to the programmer to play with
so rather than rights and wrongs there
are really only techniques and options
what we can do though is discuss the
advantages and disadvantages of the
different techniques to help inform the
decisions that we will make about which
patterns to use on a case-by-case basis